this is my iPhone which is perfect and
this is Google's first ever grossly
overpriced foldable phone hashtag team
pixel well at least they got these
things right let's open it up what do we
got in here all right look at that yep
copying Apple in every single way from
the pull tabs to this there you go let's
get it out of the box
and here it is we have Google's very own
Galaxy Z fold four I mean look at that
it's basically the same you got this
nice little goldish tone to it all the
way around not too shabby let's check
out the presentation honestly
I gotta say a little bit meh and now for
the moment of truth let's open this bad
boy up yeah that was kind of hard to
open it what is that crease do you guys
see that crease let me show you look at
that
massive crease man what are these guys
this is like Galaxy Z fold one style
well I guess let's turn it on and see
what this display
are you kidding me look at these bezels
side cam check this out massive bezels
what is this and this is like probably
bigger bezels than the original Z fold
literally like twice as thick as my
iPhone's bezels as you can see right
here and look at that of course the
bezels are so big they have to have a
black background just to hide them I
will give them props for the thickness
just showing you comparing my iPhone
take this case cook case off yep you can
fold it down like this the iPhone is
definitely a bit thicker so some props
right there and for some reason this
thing literally does not fold flat if
you look from the side it kind of has an
angle where it doesn't open all the way
and it feels like you're gonna like rip
the display off just look at this it has
wobble
I mean okay I guess it's not as bad as
the iPhone all right whatever the iPhone
does wobble more but that's because the
camera is killer I bet it's a lot better
than the camera on this pixel honestly
this is actually pretty nice it feels it
feels good okay I gotta get on props it
feels really good the design looks good
as well just look at that the camera
bump isn't that bad I kind of like it
I've been sitting here for like 10
minutes waiting for this thing to get
set up what kind of chip is in here I
gotta find out because it seems insanely
slow the iPhone gets set up like
basically instantly so what's going on
oh it looks like they have a fingerprint
scanning right here built into the power
button of course I prefer face ID
because it happens automatically it's
instant so much better than a
fingerprint swipe to navigate yeah of
course They're copying Apple's app
switcher yeah just like that literally
what they're showing off and finally we
are logged in this definitely feels
really smooth like 120 hertz that is
good let's test out the hinge
he sent let's see oh it's kind of hard
to close man like you really gotta apply
pressure almost feels like you're gonna
crack it or something but seriously do
you guys see that crease look at that
that crease that's like old Jen I mean I
know it's thin but seriously let's close
this up let's take a look at this
display oh okay wow all right this is
actually not too bad this is pretty big
look at that just a little bit smaller
than the iPhone but man this actually
looks and feels really nice I mean I
don't have anything bad to say about
this comparing the thickness it's
definitely quite a bit thicker than the
iPhone of course it's folded in half and
it feels like a brick but honestly it's
kind of like a nice premium brick an
eighteen hundred dollar brick in your
pocket of course I love that it's got
USBC compared to lightning on the iPhone
that sucks gotta get rid of it I'm so
glad it's going away so happy about that
for the iPhone and for the pixel but man
this thing attracts fingerprints almost
even worse than the iPhone which is
already bad with this space black color
you're gonna have to clean this all the
time but now getting into the really
important stuff the first thing that I
really want to compare is the speaker
quality difference because you can see
this thing is basically wait did it just
close my app okay keep it wait a second
is it literally freezing I just unboxed
this thing it can't even open YouTube it
crashed anyway I want to test out the
speakers because this thing's basically
like twice as big as the iPhone it
should be better right but before I move
on I've got to show you a product that's
perfect for both of these phones the 360
Universal magnetic charging cable from
our sponsor static this right here is
the last charging cable you'll ever need
to buy since it supports basically all
devices including iPhones iPads and
Androids like the pixel with these three
little adapters that simply plug into a
charging port like this and now I can
use a single magnetic cable to instantly
swap between charging the lightning
iPhone and the USBC pixel and it even
comes with a micro USB adapter for older
devices like this for instant magnetic
charging it's got a really nice braided
cable that won't Fray and the connector
itself rotates 300 in 60 degrees and
even folds 180 degrees both ways for a
right angle connection so check out the
static 360 Universal magnetic charging
cable as well as their static 360 pro
cable which supports blazing fast 100
watt magnetic charging by using the link
in the description below and never have
to buy another cable again and now let's
test out these speakers
foreign
[Music]
guys are you kidding me the speaker's on
this thing first of all there's so much
quieter there's basically no bass no
mids it just sounds kind of like
scratchy sure they're decent they're
fine for listening to something but
honestly if you're gonna listen to some
music or some YouTube videos You're
Gonna Want the speakers from the iPhone
they're so much better I mean eighteen
hundred dollars and the speakers aren't
even that good and now let's move on to
display quality I have an HDR YouTube
video right here to kind of see the
differences and honestly it's looking
like to me from here that the iPhone
actually is brighter look those
highlights really pop whereas they feel
pretty muted on the pixel just look at
that oh look how bright that is it's
probably blowing out my camera it is so
bright everything looks really really
good of course this is a 16x9 video so
both of them have black bars but look at
those massive bars on the Google pixel
fold yes the display section is bigger
in terms of kind of like the screen real
estate of the YouTube video but honestly
not that much bigger yes that's one of
the biggest reasons why you'd get a
foldable phone and it's just not giving
you that much better of an experience
yes of course you can kind of zoom in to
fill to use all the display but now look
how much it crops in compared to zooming
in on the iPhone but nevertheless
they're both very similar with the
iPhone having the lead and looking
better in terms of display quality but
now one thing I really want to test out
is the performance differences let's go
ahead and test geekbench 6 because this
thing does not have a very powerful chip
not at all especially for the eighteen
hundred dollar price this thing has the
tensor G2 which is the same chip that
comes in the pixel 7 so you're not
really getting a really powerful or
premium chip so let's compare it to
Apple's latest a16 bionic and there you
go the iPhone is done and we're still
waiting on the pixel man this is gonna
make man I've been recording this video
for a while this thing is so slow taking
forever for this geekbench test all
right whatever while I'm waiting for
this slow pixel I've got to give a shout
out to our partner K school for their
new Cloud Kush case which is probably
the most comfortable case I've ever held
because of its rounded Edge air cushion
technology which absorbs shocks with
three meter military drop protection but
it also looks great and feels silky
smooth solid and very grippy in the hand
with its rounded design that fits
perfectly into your palm it also comes
in a bunch of other colors all with
transparent backs to show off your
iPhone's finish so go ahead and check
out the discount in info and links down
in the description below and finally the
pixel is done and would you look at that
the iPhone is literally over twice as
fast in terms of the single core score
can you believe it it's almost half the
price but faster over twice as fast and
in terms of the single core 72 faster
than the pixel fold that means
everything that you do including web
browsing opening apps General
performance is going to be faster a lot
faster on the iPhone you know what let's
just do it let's test speedometer 2.1 to
see the difference in actual web
browsing speed that you're going to
experience day to day and look at that
we have our scores the iPhone has 367
runs per minute compared to only
97.4 with the slower chip on the pixel
foe that is crazy over three times
faster web browsing that's of course
because Safari is more efficient than
Chrome from Google as well so that's a
big difference and you know what let's
go ahead and test the graphics
performance between these two using gfx
bench we're going to do the 4K Aztec
Ruins High tier off-screen test there
you go it's done it looks like we have
22.9 FPS on the iPhone 13 FPS on the
pixel so the iPhone is 76 faster in
terms of Graphics as well so if you want
to do some gaming you're actually going
to be able to take advantage of that 120
hertz display on the iPhone with all of
that graphics performance probably not
so much the pixel fold and now let's
finally finish off with the cameras and
see how much better they are on the
iPhone first of all the inner selfie
camera on the pixel actually debuted on
the pixel 3 from 2000 and 18 and looking
at it right now it doesn't look too bad
let's actually take a quick little photo
and same thing on the iPhone all right
here we go let's look at the differences
oh wow wait a second is this really the
oh my goodness this quality is terrible
look at that look how sharp the iPhone
is compared to this you could literally
see it right here and now I also just
went out and took a bunch of photos with
the rear cameras which the pixel does
have some decent ones an ultra wide a
main and a telephoto which is actually
5x so it's pretty good but one thing I
noticed is that the pixel automatically
crops in just look at this photo look
how cropped in it is this is a 1x
compared to a 1x on the iPhone so let's
go ahead and kind of zoom in and look at
the Quality difference here right away
you could tell that the iPhone is more
detailed just look at that zooming in on
that sign whereas here it doesn't even
let you zoom in but it is really really
blurry right there and then same thing
for this 2x shot if I zoom in on the
Comfort Inn in Suites you could see that
the iPhone looks better just look at all
these leaves and the trees whereas here
it's all really soft and blurry so it's
doing better and the 2x shot as well and
then this is a 5x so it should do very
well here so let's compare oh look at
that
the iPhone is giving us better 5x shots
as well definitely more sharp the colors
pop better as well and then finally the
ultra wide and for some reason the pixel
looks really really muted the highs just
aren't popping like they should for
example if I zoom in here you could see
how the highlights on the iPhone pop
just like in real life but everything
here this looks really cool and brought
down no saturation no contrast
definitely a lot less sharp and then
finally this photo right here you can
see just how much cropped in it is on
the pixel and if we zoom in we could see
that basically the pixel is a lot less
sharp and it's just not reproducing the
colors that the iPhone can that deep red
and the gold this just all looks muted
So based on that I've got to say that
the iPhone camera is quite a bit better
than the one on the 1800 dollar pixel
fold so with all that said what is my
conclusion well honestly this is a
pretty nice foldable I don't like the
big big bezels everything else is pretty
good 120 hertz the chip is definitely
old it's not that fast twice as fast on
the iPhone web browsing is faster
basically the iPhone is a better phone
than the pixel fold I'm excited to see
what Apple's gonna do when they
eventually release their foldable phone
it's probably going to be insane well
you guys let me know your thoughts down
in the comment section below and click
the circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one definitely check
out one of those two right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
foreign